[Music]
hey everybody matinee 67 and look tom is
back yeah yeah we got three of them
Dracula yeah yeah we got a Netflix one
we got a shutter one and Ian one from
yeah go stories from India yeah a movie
one and a movie theater one that grudge
yeah so we're gonna talk about yeah
we'll talk about that order they were
well watched all right so the first
we're gonna be talking about is uh one
that's kind of been reviewed a lot it's
kind of like was a big deal when it came
out this is the new Dracula series
miniseries really that premiered on
Netflix now I think it premiered on BBC
one in the UK like over three successive
nights January 1st 2nd 3rd and then
Netflix got it presumably
internationally on the 4th so they
dropped it's a three Episode retelling
of Dracula yeah each one's about an hour
to half so it's kind of like three
movies it's kind of like three movies
and what like a trilogy yes like the
Dracula trilogy what they did with this
one I kind of liked it it's a myth it's
a mixed bag it's it is it's a lot of
good stuff and it's got some other stuff
something like well there was a little
yeah what they did was that they took
every Dracula story you know including
and rice vampires and kind of made it
into one continuous story like okay it's
got a lot of stuff you'll remember like
you know Carfax Abbey
well Dracula in the original story gets
killed in Carfax Abbey you know I'm this
one and this one he actually never
really goes there does he I don't think
it ever makes it there yeah and some has
a lot of the same characters but there
is a gender swap in one of them and
they're not really the same characters
it's almost kind of like a parallel
universe
Dracula sort of which I think if this
was I mean I'm probably most people know
because like I said this is this was
like a really popular thing and a lot of
people are reviewed it um this was
written and directed by Mark Gatiss and
Steven Moffat who
a lot of people know they've done Doctor
Who they did Sherlock yeah I could feel
it um well this is very much along that
same line because that's kind of their
thing where they like to take like 19th
century literature and kind of like mix
it up bring it into the modern era
sometimes or give it like a modern
sensibility even if they set it back in
the time I should say to that I've I've
seen like bits of Sherlock I've seen
bits of Doctor Who I'm not like a you
know I don't I haven't watch like the
whole series but I know that this is
kind of their style and this is
something that they do I uh however I do
really like Mark Gatiss is he did the
history of horror which was like it long
too like a three-part documentary about
the history of horror movies and he's
also done one that came out like in
conjunction with this called in search
of Dracula which I've also heard is
really good he's super into Hammer
movies yeah and there is an actually one
of my favorite moments in the third
episode which is the one that a lot of
which is the most controversial that a
lot of people are like talking about
there's a great shout out to the 1958
Christopher Lee Peter Cushing Dracula in
that one that I recognized immediately
having doing someone running across the
table and jumping I was pulling curtains
down yeah I was like hey Dracula yeah
the three movies Dracula evolves a lot
yeah he starts off kind of being almost
kind of like Klaus Kinski's nos Farhat
too mixed with a little bit of Gary
Oldman Oldman yet of Dracula in the very
beginning all right and then he kind of
evolves into more like a Christopher Lee
type Dracula and eventually he basically
almost comes becomes full-blown Lestat
d'lai in court looking at it they're
trying to cover all bases two men to
make all vampire characters and all
vampire stories have relevance in this
story it seems like they do everything
that all of the vampire movies did
pretty much or tried to it almost seems
like they're trying to synthesize trying
to synthesize all of the vampire myths
and all that and all the subsequent
adaptations like all the different
because I mean obviously the Dracula
story came in a long time and some
people that are like freaking out about
this being like wildly different from
novel but it's like a lot of the hammer
babies were why nots parity it was what
helped be different from the novel yeah
in the third episode where it's taking
place kind of in the more modern era you
can feel a lot of the eighties vampire
movies you can feel like Queen of the
Damned movie in it interviewer yeah
Empire just all that even blade there's
any kind of felt a little bit like blade
it also kind of felt like Torchwood yeah
it gave me a it's not it's not a bad
series it's I think it's a pretty good
series there are some things in it that
thought were a little bit hokey kind of
forced you know I don't know it's kind
of forced like there is a what's what's
the girl's name which one the one that
was in all three of the damn movies so
none the Nugget that van helsing yeah
but there's a van Helsing in it but of
course it's it's not the van Helsing you
know it's a female although it's similar
she's a vampire hunter in a way yeah
it's it's well done I see why they did
that because they had to have a long
story arc over three stood over three
yeah and they were doing a lot of
different stuff with the novel you know
what I mean it's like how do you feel
about this because I've watched like a
bunch of people's reviews of it and it
seems like most people really dug the
first - yeah and then the third one was
getting very well liked wildly mixed
reviews which I that's probably
understandable because that was the one
that was deviated the most from the
source material I mean I kind of liked
you know the first you know section of
it is kind of like sort of taken from
the first third of the novel where
Jonathan Harker is at the you know
Castle Dracula in 1897 and then you know
he escapes and like you know goes to the
nunnery and stuff like that and that's
kind of where it starts to deviate I do
love that the second episode which
probably was my favorite one of all of
them which is called blood vessel which
I thought was hilarious actually take
takes place on the Demeter during
Dracula's voyage yeah to England yeah
so I liked that they cuz I feel like
good job with that but I like they did I
liked this at all I mean it was but it's
like it was
very short trip yeah it didn't really
say what exactly happened on the ship it
was just kind of like they found like
some ships logs like a B because it's
you know the novels epistolary it's all
in like letters and they got a hoards
they got a whole movies worth a story
just out of the damage it was almost
like a murder mystery I thought was kind
of cool too like knives out it's like
it's like yeah you knew who I mean
obviously it was someone to like
everybody but it's like the people on
the ship didn't know that but yeah so
that was probably my favorite one yeah
and I was expecting and a third one from
him to actually show up to Carfax Abbey
but it doesn't it does not quite it
doesn't not quite
although okay that's what they wanted to
do I don't think I would've done it that
way but I guess it worked they wanted to
show him in a modern setting yeah some
of it was successful like some of it I
liked you know I like the idea of him
being in a modern era and like I said
they're not the first people to do that
that was they done lots they had to
synthesize all those modern stories
right that's what I mean I think that's
what I think I wasn't expecting it to go
that way just because the first two took
place you know in the 19th century so I
was kind of expecting the third one too
as well so like when you kind of get to
the end of the second one and he arrives
at Whitby and it's like you know it's
2020 you know and I was kind of like oh
well I'm not sure how I feel about this
something that I liked some of it not so
much I I have to say that it took me a
while to get used to how funny it was
because there's like a lot of humor in
it and I guess I wasn't expecting that
at first like when I started watching
the first episode and so like the first
time they were like trying like being
funny and [ __ ] like that I'm like what
and like the tone seemed kind of weird
but like after I kind of rolled with it
I kind of got into it more um but I
really liked the guy Kleist bang who
plays Dracula was like really good and
what's the woman's name that played her
name's dolly something who played a
sister Agatha and then like a later
incarnation of a van Helsing you know
she was great in it too and like I think
the best thing about it was like kind of
the interplay between the two of them
too you know vampire versus vampire
hunter and
you know this kind of cat-and-mouse game
with the two of them and her trying to
destroy him and stuff like that um like
I said how you feel about it this is not
a faithful adaptation by any Church the
imagination there's a lot of stuff that
they took from the book but they
reinterpret it in a lot of ways you know
what I mean and they focused on some
stuff like I said I really like the
middle part where they focused on the
journey the Demeter and they made like a
whole hour and a half episode out of
that which you don't see in that many I
mean usually even in the book it's just
kind of like yeah the ship showed up on
at Whitby and like the dude was chained
to the wheel and like a wolf jumped off
it and then that's kind of all you hear
about it pretty much the best part of
all these of this series if you asked me
was that they opened up a concept that
they really didn't explore even in and
rice books well I guess they exported a
little bit but Dracula didn't really
know what the powers of a vampire were
yeah and he really didn't know what was
possible so he was doing experiments
like back in the day yeah hundreds of
years ago he was doing experiments to
try to figure out what what the
limitations of it what would happen if
you did this or did that you you know
like what happens if you turn an event
or turn a baby into a vampire what
happens if you you know have sex with or
have sex with a with a vampire woman can
you have a child write all kinds of
stuff when it comes out available yeah
welcome and what comes out you know I
mean if she ever did so he's trying to
figure out how to reproduce and he
hasn't figured out how to reproduce and
I don't think he ever does in the book
that kind of yeah I think it's it's good
because it's like if you think if you
were Dracula like if vampires were real
clearly and you had been around I mean
at the point at the beginning which is
takes place in 1897 he had been around
for you know what three four five
hundred years four hundred years so
after that long you'd kind of get bored
and it's like you wouldn't really have
any other vampires to like talk to like
a master vampire that could tell you hey
these are the rules and also so you kind
of have to
I'm out by yourself yeah so I figured
that you know there's kind of like a
little bit of that going on even though
he's you know he's essentially like he's
not like an existential Anne Rice type
of vampire really he's like pretty much
just a predator and he's very like
snarky and suave and charming and
everything like that another thing that
I kind of liked an element that they
added to it that I don't really I don't
think this this was gone into in the
book but um where he basically chose his
victims sort of carefully because he was
absorbing parts of their personality
their memories their their knowledge
like things they knew how to do yeah
that's kind of like it reminding a
little bit of a stop because I think the
Lestat vampires were kind of like that
yeah there was mostly reading minds and
they could understand what somebody was
thinking if he had the power yeah if you
had enough power I liked it you liked
that aspect of it they also changed it
up a little bit a person if they drank a
person to death without really [ __ ]
him up real bad they came back as a as a
ghoul and I wouldn't really say as a
damn vampire more like a zombie they'd
come back almost kind of like a zombie
kind of it's like they didn't really
like they still had some of their
faculties but they weren't like a
full-blown Dracula style vampire so it
was almost like levels of it yeah and if
they if he started feeding off of him
slowly they would turn into kind of like
a a servant that could talk to a certain
extent yeah that's how I understood it
well because and that was kind of in the
book too and I feel like the book didn't
go into that because that's what
Renfield was yeah he wasn't undead I
don't think no it's just like a slave so
I assumed that Dracula had drank enough
of his blood that he was like enthralled
to him well they never get into they
never do they never knew really getting
to the possibility is Dracula making
them drink his blood right because
that's how you made a vampire and and
right and the more blood you gave them
the stronger they get yeah we're limited
to the amount of the amount you know
that you had to give in the first place
if you weren't a strong vampire giving
them a little bit of your blood might
turn them into a wee
vampire but they would never become a
strong vampire often drinking you yeah
cuz you weren't strong yeah so because
it was kind of like it was it was thin
and out that vampire blood so I don't
think they ever really addressed that
you don't think yeah it never showed him
make anyone drink his blood maybe that's
why he couldn't figure out how to
reproduce yeah maybe that's what it was
because he didn't treat you guess he
hadn't tried that you think he would try
that I mean somebody did drink his blood
later yeah what happened her but not it
was what's her face well what happened
to her um nothing right not really okay
well she she kind of like got I think
she gained like insight in the same way
that he gained insight about like heat
like she could kind of like read his
mind and stuff that's how she figured
out all that stuff that she said to him
at the end all right because I think she
was kind of so they had like some kind
of mind meld and also I think her doing
that enabled her to contact or like you
know have the mind of her ancestor
alright that's it you know Agatha's
sister Agatha you know in the modern era
so it's like it established a psychic
link between her ancestor through his
blood yeah
because so the lore is a little
different actually it wasn't a bad
series I kind of preferred that Dracula
untold story movie yeah remember that
track it on yeah yeah I like that one
better I think yeah this one like I said
if you like you know Sherlock I've heard
this is also like Steven Moffat other
one which is called Jekyll you know if
you kind of like that kind of tone that
they do where you know they're taking
like a you know a nineteenth-century
story and like mixing it up with like I
said either modern sensibilities or
setting it in the modern day and like
kind of bouncing those ideas off each
other like I said it just don't expect
you know a faithful adaptation to the
book because this is not that but really
it's like do we need that because
there's been so many adaptations of
Dracula at this point I mean the book is
like over 100 years old and it's been
made and remade into so many movies so
it's you know interesting to see what
other people do with the character I
still think probably to this day the bed
Dracula's story is that actually the one
with Gary Oldman even though it's it's
kind of the some of the effects on it
aren't really modern it's got terrible
acting yeah I still think that's
probably best some of the yeah it's a I
mean obviously Keanu Reeves and Winona
Ryder they just didn't belong in a damn
mood if those two had been switched at
and I like them as actors in other
things they didn't they dumped their
accents they're not good in period
pieces though um what no no writers a
bit better in that but is in period
pieces but as long as they don't have to
do accents if they had got Britain two
British actors to be in that I think
yeah probably would have been like the
perfect movie but just cuz everyone else
in it was great yeah they just didn't
they just had to have American stars on
damn billboard to give people in that to
get people to watch it which is kind of
a shame but they thought I think they
could have got it yeah other people
there's big names at the time yeah it's
like well it does seem like they don't
want to take a risk it's like they don't
want to say it's like you know well we
we you know the the stars are bankable
it's like they don't want to just put
like two British people that may be
Americans don't know it's like it's not
saying that that wouldn't be successful
because a lot of British movies are
successful over here with you know
people that were not as familiar with
but it's I guess it's a gamble they're
not usually willing to take although I
gotta say Klaus Kinski's Nosferatu was
pretty good he's just like a creepy Eric
in real life so it makes you sick to see
him and that's kind of the way he was
described in certain ways you know
basically just a damn rat like a rat
person rat that come out of came out of
a tomb you know that he was a plague at
playing upon mankind and Olivia and
that's what he did just got people to
[ __ ] plague and yeah it just seemed
to be real sickly and just when he would
talk he was just like a [ __ ] dork in
a certain way you know I mean just
that's what I mean in some ways I think
they just connected from I think that
nas bra to like the original f2 Beemer
now one and
you know the more recent one more recent
to the seventies but the one with the
Klaus Kinski in it I think those are
probably conclude well they're the
closest to what the characters described
like in the book at least early on like
when Harker first shows up yeah it
wasn't a magic figure at all yeah that
was the Bela Lugosi thing and that
didn't come about until Universal in
1931 like and there's better on the
silver screen at the yeah well it's like
nobody wants to see you like this it's
kind of like art I think nos Verizon is
super cool again guys haven't seen
Nosferatu Klaus Kinski see that one yeah
I think we were reviewed it didn't yet
maybe yeah we did yeah but yeah so uh
yeah this is a new Dracula like I said
peer into that kind of Doctor Who we you
know Jekyll II sherlocky type of thing
he's been watching nothing I
yeah that's true of a lot of things but
yeah it's like I actually really liked
it I know some people are kind of like
oh the first two episodes are really
good and the third and really sucked I
think the third one was a mixed bag
there's probably a couple things I would
have done differently I don't have a
problem with him like Dracula being in
the present-day or with some of the
decisions they made but um you know I
might have done a couple things
differently but all in all I thought it
was like really enjoyable and you know I
thought pretty good yeah
you
all right the second movie we watched
this week was on shudder I don't know if
it's a shutter exclusive that this was a
20/20 anthology film called ghost
stories yes go an Indian yeah I don't
see a lot of Indian horror movies no
Indian India brought it's a it's a game
with this one I mean it's good
old-fashioned writing storytelling it's
really good maybe no it was I liked it I
mean - I thought this was a cool last
movie I don't know yeah I had actually
been hearing a little bit about it I
guess I don't know if it did festivals
or anything like that but apparently the
the directors that worked on this or the
producers or whatever this is kind of
like they had done another anthology
film called lust stories that I think
was like you know four different
directors or whatever doing like you
know love stories and sex stories and
stuff like that so this is their horror
one yeah
so it has four stories and it's
interesting because I was watching a
couple other you know because I
subscribe to a couple other horror
review channels and it's interesting
that it seemed like almost everybody
liked the third segment the best even
though and didn't like the first one
even though the first one was probably
my favorite although the first or the
second was probably my favorite if I had
to pick yeah this is you think of like
um kinda like Creepshow yeah except it
has more of a classical tone to it it
even kind of had a really good score
yeah high school squirrel I liked it
each each story kind of had a slightly
its own style you could see it's um I
don't know whether over the directors
different yeah it was all he was for
different - okay yeah yeah cuz on some
of them that would that last one with
that family almost kind of felt a little
bit like a Kubrick yeah movie I was a
little bit like some shiny
there's some shiny callbacks and some of
that wasn't there there was and there in
the in the would he call it the oh no
that was that was Dracula there's a Drac
that was okay we watch them close
together sigh I just remembered that
watching this one somebody had wallpaper
that looks like the shine and carbon
yeah yeah that was in Dracula okay but
still the this one here there that um
that last one kind of felt
like a Kubrick episode or something or
had it influenced Stanley Kubrick what
it felt like to me yeah but I really
liked the score I did as well yeah this
just like this whole movie it's the the
four segments are very very different um
I will say like the first one is kind of
more like a classical ghost story um
where it's just kind of like this
she's like a homecare nurse named Samira
and she shows up at this house she's
supposed to take care of this woman that
has dementia and you know I guess the
the woman's son was supposed to be there
and he didn't show up so it's like you
know she's laying there she's gonna
there's pee everywhere and all this
other kind of stuff so there's like
stuff with her and the creepy old woman
and there's stuff with her and like [ __ ]
just dude or her boyfriend who was
supposed to Leo he's gonna leave his
wife for her blah blah blah so there's
look kind of all that kind of stuff
going I'm not gonna spoil the ending
because I actually didn't see it coming
one's almost kind of like a Twilight
Zone after it is yeah in a way a lot
they're all kind of like Twilight Zone
ups yes just cuz that's the wave creep
show was and all the anti but this one
kind of reminded me of a Twilight Zone
episode it was good that the tone was
the most modern out of them all this one
really kind of felt like some of the new
horror you know the way they yes were
the one with the monsters in it felt a
little bit more kind of throwback yeah
and there's that was the second one
wasn't it no that was the third that was
the third one okay so which one was the
second one the second one was that
really really weird one where like
remember like all the colors were kind
of like drained out of it it was almost
like black and white but not quite um it
was like these really muted colors and
it was about the woman that was pregnant
and she had and what the thing with the
birds yeah yeah you can burn yes well
that one either I really liked that one
it's just I I'm not entirely sure like I
think I kind of get what they were
really had to say a couple times and I
think maybe a little bit of maybe Indian
culture might have explained a little
bit of that I don't know if there was
some kind of mythology that they were
yeah maybe that's what having to do with
birds yeah but it was just [ __ ]
really weird it wasn't really really
creepy and it was a lot grosser than
dead know what I expected from an Indian
movie this isn't like your typical
Bollywood
[ __ ] movie we're not at all where
everything is kind of censored and it's
real super PG then a musical [ __ ]
number breaks out in the middle of the
day or yeah none of them none of that
[ __ ] our fourth one has like a little
bit of that like in the beginning of it
like not it doesn't have any dance
numbers yeah like that obvious but it
has more of that kind of like you know
Indian music video things like this big
beautiful like palatial estate but it
did kind of go along with it the other
ones are very much like like our Western
art house horror movies I mean I thought
like you said the first one was very
much like maybe like with something from
the conjuring universe like yeah that's
what I meant to say by more modern kind
of flag about the cross-pollinated with
a Twilight Zone type of vibe the second
one was very much like a very arty you
know maybe something from like a 24 or
something like that we're just has this
weird look to it I love there was body
horror in it yes it was [ __ ] weird it
was almost kind of like I almost want to
say you erase her head because some of
it was kind of really weird-looking but
not really it's just it did a little bit
of that you know time kind of vibe to it
and I guess because it was like centered
around fetuses and then like the third
one was like an Indian zombie movie yeah
they're not zombies
they're some kind of damn Indian monster
they're cannibalistic they turn into
some kind of humanoid animals that kind
of look like a damn dog man or an orc er
I said I said he looked like Evel Chong
we've got a little Jake evil Chaka yeah
cuz as soon as like he came in that was
the little girl's dad right the the
setup of that one is kind of like
there's this guy and he's sent to this
town which I guess when I looked on
Wikipedia the town is supposed to be
called B's gara which I guess means
small town just but the you know the
[ __ ] what do you call them things at
the bottom of the screen yeah subtitles
the subtitles just said small town in
big town like named them those two
things
so he's sent there because for his job I
guess he's supposed to like assess the
local school or something like that they
don't find that out till later and when
he gets there there's only two kids left
and they say that oh they ate everyone
yeah so it's kind of like what the [ __ ]
you talking about yeah so it's kind of
like this thing where they're trying to
get away from these I guess they're they
kind of act like zombies in the sense
that they shuffle around and they're
cannibals but also I think the longer
they're like that like I said they're
been they turn into big evil chauka yeah
because I think the girl's dad had been
a cannibal the longest so she looked the
most like a Chaka yeah like some of the
other ones were like we kind of look
like a cross between a Bigfoot and a dog
man that orc kinda yeah it's just just
I'm not gonna explain it just watch it's
good this one too had a little bit and
it's significant that the towns were
called bees gara and Sal gar which were
like a small town in big town because it
almost had like a little bit you
remember will we've reviewed that [ __ ]
that Brian Diaz in a movie society we're
talking about kind of like you know the
the rich people like eating off the poor
ones are sucking out the poor ones it
kind of has a little bit of social
satire in that sort of regard yeah and I
don't know if this is like an original
monster that they made up or if this is
something traditional Indian kind of
lore there seemed to be some kind of a
lore behind it there did yeah it did
seem like they didn't really explain
what they were and they didn't have to
explain because I guess they expected
you to kind of know what it was they
kind of know what was happening I mean I
just assumed it was kind of like a
zombie person that like they ate people
so long that they turned into like an
animal
it's like a zombie that's like a vampire
that turns into like a werewolf because
of all of them because apparently they
started out as regular people right it
because then it turns into a mummy and
it turns it to a Frankenstein the
evolution the mom yeah yeah through all
the features then he turns into the gill
man
yeah [ __ ] ends up as Godzilla
yeah I would watch that movie yeah
yeah just cover all the [ __ ]
Possible's in what so like it I guess
cabin in the woods kind of did that'll
yeah I don't think the India would
attempt something like that I would
watch the [ __ ] out of that yeah and it
starts with an egg like a xenomorph
that's is that because they go zoom on
it goes to wall and then it does the
facehugger that turns into chucky yeah
yeah yeah oliver in there yeah but yeah
so the third one is kind of more like
you know kind of your post-apocalyptic
yeah zombie type scenario it's like a
little bit of a walking dead but with
some social satire on top of it as well
yeah then the fourth one is kind of like
like I said this is the most Bollywood
and I don't mean that in a bad way
that's it like I said there's no big
dance awfull amorous but it's like
glamorous it's like it's like a wealthy
guy named Dhruv and he like a you know
he wants to do an arranged marriage
so he marries his woman named era and
they're both like really young and
beautiful and he and she was from a
Christian family yes well no he is he is
okay yeah yeah cuz that that definitely
plays you into the story because I think
you actually missed that discussion yeah
but um so they get married and he has
this like humongous like gorgeous
mansion and she's all happy and
everything like that but then she finds
out that her new like really foxy
husband also has this weird thing where
he's apparently the only person that can
see the ghost of his grandma who died 20
years ago and so he's always like
talking to her and it's like good night
greedy and he's like all really weird
about it and she's like super weird of
that about it as you would be and um so
so she starts to get a little upset
because she thinks her husband's nuts
that he's seeing this but then
apparently his whole family is kind of
in on this [ __ ] it's like oh you know we
can't make grand granny mad like he's
the only one they could see her blah
blah so you find out all this other kind
of stuff about it
that one actually you actually get to
see a very old Indian woman saying look
at my [ __ ] face make me laugh yeah
forgot to mention that Oh got to mention
that all these stories are in Hindi
mostly there's some English sprinkle
throw there in English out there but
it's subtitles now this last one has the
most English in it yeah and when she
starts Cushing's she starts oh [ __ ] and
I guess he can probably he can get away
with that I let it but easier
yeah man there's a lot of swearing in
the third one mostly former but like I
said um I could it was funny because I'm
sitting there thinking like when I was
watching it I was like now did they want
to see like the way it ended and stuff
which like I said I'm not gonna spoil it
but did they want to make it seem like
she deserved it or like she got to come
up in but I was like I felt for her it's
like I would feel weirded out to like if
I married into some family and like the
guy was like talking to a ghost and it's
like you couldn't and like all his
family was like really weird about it
and he was like had to ask the ghost
before he can do anything and it's like
the ghost kept like peeking in on him
like when they were having sex and stuff
and he'd be like oh hey grandma we're
just you know having sex and I'd be like
yeah that's a little weird yeah so I
didn't blame her at all for kidding but
you know it's like that one was probably
like the funniest yeah um and some of
the reviews I was watching earlier it
seemed like they really liked the zombie
one but it's like everybody kind of
hated the fourth one but I thought the
four was good I liked it it's it was
probably if I had to pick it was
probably my least favorite but I still
really liked it I thought it was amazing
the people that are saying this are
proud like 15 16 years old well they're
guys yeah it's just though you gotta
take the movie as a whole
yeah I like the anthology I thought I
could stand up there with some of the
some of the best American anthologies I
thought it could do I actually liked it
don't worry I I thought I liked it more
than some of the more recent anthologies
it is it's a lot better than a lot of
the recent Hollywood stuff um yeah this
is
a game movie I liked it I think I liked
this one that this might be a bold
statement but I think I liked this one
better than a nightmare cinema which I
an analogy that I reviewed the other day
which I liked I actually quite liked but
that was I feel like that was a more
mixed bag than this one because this one
I feel like all four stories were pretty
strong even though they were very very
different you know what I mean yeah so
yeah this is on shudder if you're not
averse to reading subtitles because like
I said this is mostly in Hindi there's
some English and they're mostly the
swearing it's a strong entry from India
but yeah I really dug it I thought it
was really good I was just like I
thought all the stories were great and
yeah you know we'll see what else these
guys have up their sleeves I don't know
if they're gonna do any more horror
because like I said they already did
like a romance one like this and they
did another one to you but we'll see
you
all right the third movie we saw this
week we went to the theater to see the
remake reboot sequel ish kind of The
Grudge yeah yeah you can already tell
how this is gonna go well okay now
here's what I will say like I said I
don't watch reviews or anything like
that before I go see the movie however I
had heard through the grapevine that
this movie was getting terrible reviews
that I had like 15 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes like from both critics and
audiences so it wasn't a kind of thing
where there was that going on so that
said it was not as bad as I was
expecting because I was expecting it to
be a total trash fire like with with a
score that low um it actually wasn't so
it wasn't as bad as I was expecting
however this is another movie and I
mentioned this last week when I was
talking about the remake the remake of
Jacob's Ladder this is just like another
movie that you just kind of watch it and
you're just like why like why was it
made it's a it's not terrible it's not
like you you know you don't want to like
shoot yourself afterward or anything
like that but it's just kind of like I
don't really see the point of it you
know what I'm saying here's the problem
you have a movie that doesn't have any
really interesting characters driving it
they don't even really have a very
interesting dialogue you can't you don't
care about anybody in the movie yeah the
pacing of it is [ __ ] crazy
it's just very boring you have
paranormal [ __ ] happening I guess it's
and you don't care and it's doing a lot
of flashing back and you don't care and
then it kind of it does have some
disturbing imagery in a few scenes it's
all like yeah I mean they did go for an
r-rating Joe their credit they didn't
try to like you know dumb it down to
like a pg-13 which I did appreciate but
there is no real driving narrative and
there's no real driving characters in
this story and then it ends up and kind
of a I wouldn't even call it a climax
just to finish ends up in a finish there
was it's just kind of good there was no
payoff for watching
[ __ ] thing yeah I see what you say
I'm talking about like I sat through
that for this yeah I thought it was
gonna build up for something it never
really did I feel like I heard that the
International landing was different that
the end that you know what I mean that
they're like was a little bit more that
like for some reason they didn't put in
the American one person I don't know why
but it had some good ideas I had some
good imagery but there wasn't even
anyone could really kind of I needed a
character yeah you could get through
this movie with and it's and there none
of these characters because the guy that
directed it Nicholas Pesci or pêche or
whatever his name is I mean he did the
eyes of my mother which I really liked
very arthouse he also did another one
called piercing which I haven't seen yet
but a lot of people have recommended to
me that it slept like that's like a
really good underrated movie so I feel
like they kind of gave him this
franchise now okay now you had never
seen any of the grudge movies see you
really like I'm judging it on it's just
yeah now I saw the original Juwan which
I liked
I saw the 2004 American remake with
Sarah Michelle Gellar which was fine I
remember it being alright um I will say
that I'm not so I haven't seen they did
like a bunch of other you know they did
The Grudge three which I think went
directed DVD now in Japan they have like
a [ __ ] ton of grudge movies they just
kept doing them there's like a crossover
with the ring like the two girls from
like the ghost girl from the ring and
the ghost girl from the grudge or like
fighting it out which I have not seen so
I'm not like a huge fan of the franchise
but that said it's like I feel like the
same I had the same problem with this
movie that I had with the original
grudge movie and the American remake in
that the way that they're told is not it
you know it's not like a standard
storytelling arc where you know what I
mean where it's kind of like a build-up
and then a climax and then a dana mod
they didn't really have that it's kind
of like done more episodic or cyclical
which is what you see in Japanese which
a lot of Asian movies are just [ __ ]
that um it can be done well but in The
Grudge movies I just feel like
particularly in the first one which I
thought was really cool like I really
liked
you know the ghost woman and the little
boy like with the you know that noise
they made and stuff like that which they
did do in this movie even though the
ghosts are different but I feel like it
was kind of a case where you're seeing
like this the ghosts like tormenting
this one family for a third of the movie
and then it stops and then another
family moves in and oh it happens again
you know tomates so it just happened
three times and then the movie ends so i
feel like when you structure a movie
like that
one you can't really build any forward
momentum you're not spending enough time
with the characters to really get
invested in them or like you know care
what happens to them or if something bad
happens to them and it gets to a point
point where it's just like repetitive
but it's just like you know oh the
ghosts got these people oh and now
here's more people and now I guess we're
gonna get that in pretty much the same
exact way she can write better than I
can she's a writer so but me is just
somebody in the audience I'm like why is
this happening why you know why they
showing this to me you know like yeah
okay that's weird
alright when's the story gonna start and
you go okay this is kind of a story yeah
okay Oh what did I just see this oh did
I mean there just didn't I just see this
again and the thing to you doesn't make
any sense to the interview about The
Grudge mythology like the mythology that
was set up in the first Jew on the
mythology is not that complicated I mean
the mythology is basically a house where
something horrible happened in the case
of John it was just like this horrible
multiple murder and it's like you know
that so the curse like lingers around
and anybody who goes into the house even
if just for a few minutes
like we'll carry that curse until like
they end up dying which is kind of a
common theme in a lot of Asian or the
same thing with the ring and stuff like
that but is so I feel like once you've
established a premise that simple
when you're watching it it's just like
more of the same like you know that
everybody that goes in that house is
[ __ ] and there's not much you can do
about it and they're gonna be [ __ ] in
pretty much the same way this one did
try to do something different like I
said the the two ghosts that were in I
can't remember their names it was like a
woman and a little kid the two ghosts
that were in the original
Juwan are not in this one basically
they've done something more like they've
done something more like it's a it's
like a contagion you know at the
beginning because this is supposed to be
when they first announced that they were
doing this they initially said it was
gonna be a reboot and then they said no
it's gonna be a sequel what it actually
ended up being was what they call a side
quo they said it in 2004 because it's
supposed to be going on concurrently
with the American remake the one with
Sarah Michelle Gellar a different house
so there's like this woman that works at
this one house in Japan and then she
comes back to her house in Pennsylvania
and she has brought the curse with her
so the so the movies not said in Japan
only the very like the first couple of
minutes are set in Japan and they show
this woman coming back and you're
presuming that she brought it back to
the United States and then it just you
know it focuses around her house you
know her family gets killed and then it
kind of goes now they do have a
through-line in detective Muldoon who
was played by Andrea Riseborough who was
in Mandy and she was [ __ ] great in
that and she's good in this I really
liked her in this all thing everything
new yeah it's like I I feel like all the
acting and this is fine but they didn't
really give anybody anything to work
with yeah you know what I mean no lies
it's it's the movie the tone of the
movie is very bland and monotonous yes
and it's like some of the scenes like
they're having pretty much the same
conversation again you know what I mean
it's kind of like yeah we've established
that that the house is cursed and he
never even ate is Mandy Mandy is one of
my favorite films yeah [ __ ] love
Mandy yeah and it's and I just feel like
she was wasted on this it's they're
trying to achieve some kind of tone that
that I guess the Japanese movies have
yeah and but from from my point of view
not really not knowing anything just
going in to see this movie it's just a
bland tone although I've heard that
people that you know people that even
really like the first grudge movie and
even the remake didn't like this Winnie
it's not as scary it wasn't really scary
like it's just jump scares you can tell
when they're come is telegraphed and you
know and it's always you know
it's all like that yeah and it's a shame
because there's like so there's a great
actors in this like I like I said I've
liked this directors of movies weird
situations and [ __ ] for the old ladies
everything lin shaye she was the old
lady in this I love her she's like good
and everything and she committed she was
like pretty much the only person that
looked like they were having a good time
yes because she got to play like a green
now that I think what acting was good
yeah there's no nothing wrong with the
actors there's no score yeah I just felt
like there was no driving force behind
the [ __ ] yeah he said there's no
momentum yeah there's no reason to watch
the movie it's very just kind of bland
in like it's not scary
and I feel like there's not enough time
because they jump back and forth yeah
you don't know anything 2004 to 2006 and
they try to establish some
characterization you know they do try to
they're you know but they're only
they're not really that successful at it
because it's like you'll have five
minutes with this family and they're
having a convert the tone is pretty much
the same throughout the whole thing so
it's just kind of like monotonous and uh
there's no one you really root for yeah
when you can really kind of relate to
there aren't very many conversations and
the ones they does they do have a common
are boring and you already know all of
the stuff that they're saying because
like I said this you know The Grudge
mythology is not complicated I can't I
spent that um last two thirds of the
movie going god this needs to hurry up
and it's only an hour and 34 minutes but
it seems a lot longer right you know
what I mean just needs to hurry up and I
said why this you know they need they
need to edit this to go a little faster
yeah and you know and I but if they
edited it to go a little faster it's
probably a 20 minute movie if they took
out all the unnecessary yeah I just feel
like I said I see what they're doing I
know that they were trying to make it in
the spirit of the original which like I
said was more episodic or a more
cyclical type story I think it worked in
the first grudge but in this one they
jump back and forth so much that you
don't really have time to get to know
any of the characters you know what I
mean because you spend such a brief time
with them and then it goes back to this
other story and it keeps jumping back
and forth in time and so you
you know there's nothing to really get a
handle on like I said the acting is fine
it looked was good yeah it looked cool
like I had like a nice look to it
um this it was the writing I think it
was and it just seemed like like I said
it's a shame because everyone involved
seemed like a talented person but it's
just like it got all put together and it
just kind of came out it well it could
have it should have been turned into
kinda like a standard paranormal
investigation of some [ __ ] haunted
houses and he just left it just very
direct and it probably been fun yeah
yeah wouldn't have been all that
memorable yeah you know it would have
been at least you didn't find a cetera
yeah I mean this would just it just
seemed like like I said if I was
expecting it to be like horrific ly bad
it wasn't horrific ly bad it was just
really really boring it was just kind of
like the Jacob's Ladder remake like I'm
saying it's just it is not terrible it's
just not there's no point to it and
there's no point in like wasting time on
it although like I said they might make
another one because it's already made
twice its budget back so this one yeah
yeah I mean it may it may it was a shot
with the phone but maybe no well it cost
ten million dollars supposedly but it's
like they other nap in there like we
made our money
it met expectations for its first week
and it's already made 19 million which
you know what I mean there was that good
for something smaller three other people
watching it in the theater with us at
five o'clock in the afternoon huh they
kept wandering around back there with
the favorite boring I thought plus that
one old guy with the loud popcorn I
think yeah well there's a minute set
down it's sort of rattle is like a
popcorn bag there's a certain class a
movie go or do you know now you know
that just [ __ ] walks around in the
movies it just goes from one movie to
them I guess says they don't really stop
yeah I mean I I mean the kids that work
there they don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] they
don't give a [ __ ] they don't clean the
bathroom floor be [ __ ] stickiness
bosom it's a nicest theater it's almost
when there's a man clean that [ __ ]
bathroom floor and they'd probably be
like no man I think seven dollars but
yeah so like I said this this is kind of
getting savaged pretty much everywhere
you know it's it's not as it's not
offensively terrible it's just yeah it's
just really
not worth watching it was just kind of
dull like I said it's a shame cuz
everybody involved is talented and I
feel like you know they were doing what
they could do but it's just a reason
come together movies that we've seen
blow this one out of the [ __ ] water
yeah there's really there's just no even
that even a silly one even the silly one
about to keep the kids in the in the in
the amusement park
what Hellfest how fast you still
remember though even Hellfest would blow
this out of the water it yeah well I
brother this was fun I would rather
watch how fast yeah yeah like you said
at least that one was I mean it was dumb
but I was laughing but at least it was a
good time yeah yeah yeah this one it
there's just not really any reason for
this to exist I don't really see what
the audience for it is um you know what
I mean it's like like I said why have
they made like a million of these grudge
movies in Japan I don't know they have
but they're starting to do it escape
room blew this one away member escape
room yeah I actually didn't mind as a
lot of people didn't like it really it's
gone oh yeah I'm waiting for the sequel
I likes caper yeah I think it did okay
but it's just you know and a lot of
reviewers that are watching too they
make the point that for whatever reason
January is kind of the month when all
the studios like dump their stuff that
they don't think is gonna do very well
because here I guess they're hoping
people won't know it is like Star Wars
well that actually they know that you
know this comes out at Christmas like
that's when your big movies come out
your big movies come out in summer or
around Christmas time after the holidays
that's kind of when you put your ones
that are that are either like a big risk
or that they kind of know aren't that
great and they're just kind of like it's
too January's like the movie dumping
ground and for whatever reason the first
one that they the big studio is put out
in January is always a horror movie like
his last year it was a scape room and a
lot of people gonna like that what I
liked it I liked it too but it's like a
lot of people that end [ __ ] so um
but this one you know kind of the first
big horror movie out of the year and man
although you know it looks like some
good ones were coming I'm very excited
about antlers we saw the trailer for
that during this one - actually Gretel
and Hansel looks pretty good that
actually looks pretty decent it did it
looked like oh it looks like a big like
homage to old Suspiria like the
yeah I saw the damn poster too
gretel-ann hands oh my god I [ __ ]
suck that's all trailer like oh man it's
got the girl that was in it chapter one
that play Beverly yeah that girl's in it
yeah it looks pretty cool actually it
looks creepy I want to see that and I
want to see antlers and dr. sleep wasn't
bad a lot of people didn't like it
I liked dr. sleep I did to you yeah but
yeah it looks like there's some good
ones coming out you know this year so
hopefully they'll be better than this
one that's of course it wouldn't be that
hard to be poor dudes movies just
entertain me that's like I said it
wasn't as bad as that we was just boring
that's all it's just it was just wasn't
fun to watch no it wasn't it was kind of
like a slog we're talking about it me to
shut it down shut this [ __ ] down
alright we'll see some more movies next
weekend we'll see you next time
you